une production du studio sf météo sans
fil le podcast où on parle de ce qu'on
veut nous inviter date seach ph quand un
gosse d'une plante ou yom question que
toi qu'est ce qui est super important
quand tu vas chez le médecin lui demande
d'enlever des pantalons d'avoir des
belles bêtes
qu'est ce qui est super important quand
sur un mannequin chez vous c est quand
même plus les peines d'amendés boxer un
peu comme ça qu'est ce qui est super
important quand tu vis tous les jours
puis tu veux juste sentir bien même tout
par des bobettes même des morceaux puis
je pense pour y amener un gamin et je me
disais il est dit dans un bar le sait
mais ton qui se veut bien s'en tirer
pour le thé legault qui bien dans sa
peau le dit m c'était pas des belles
bêtes c'est la sagesse c'est la sagesse
c'est pour ceux qui on est ultra heureux
cette semaine de s'associer à eux deux
une compagnie québécoise qui font des
boxeurs puis des bobettes dans le fond
tant pour les hommes que pour les femmes
une fabrique extrêmement douce ça me
semble être des boxeurs très confortable
avec des design complètement fly et qui
sont incroyables si on n o 2 babet fluo
à jour avec des champignons pillon dre
des boxeurs d'halloween vous pouvez
aller voir sur leur site ils font des
package peut avoir des package rindom
fait choisir les bobettes que vous
voulez il ya plein de désigner vraiment
beaucoup beaucoup design et suzie studio
sf 30
vous allez avoir 30% de rabais sur votre
facture globale fait que ça vous permet
d'acheter des bobettes pour les dix
prochaines années qui monte au fait
vraiment longtemps le jeudi 10 à 6 si
vos bêtes of disant vous êtes souvent
commando surman mai
sur le site des remparts la cité vous
l'approprier de tirer vraiment les bacs
merci la gamme de chez on dit oye
deuxième commanditaire aujourd'hui
planète roster qui sont toujours là avec
nous fidèle au poste
on les a doublées si belle aux combats
prévosto qui est une société
d'hébergement de sites web a fait
affaire avec sûrs si vous avez un site
web si vous êtes un particulier
vous avez un blog est une entreprise
avec besoin de gros moyens ils vont
vraiment avoir une offre adaptée pour
vous les services à la clientèle gens
parlent toujours est impeccable service
24 heures sur 24 vous appelez les mêmes
problèmes j'avais des questions ils vont
répondre vont mettre du temps dans votre
projet ils vont vraiment être rapide
être efficace
ça va vraiment super bien parce que ion
plus de 70 clients plus de cent mille
sites web hébergés
ça fait genre planethoster ça fait du
monde sont basés à laval une entreprise
québécoise vraiment très fiers de
collaborer avec le planethoster checker
si vous voulez 25% sur tous vos achats
chez plaintes au sujet des codes promos
ph a trait d'union sans trait d'union
filtre à l'échec et sa merci en dise
merci à payet auteur cette semaine
d'hommes sur le sans fil on a reçu
l'avis kid un rapport qui est que qu'on
a connu dans la vie hadj est en fait le
groupe qui avait avec un dénommé lahoud
rapport moins connus l'aïkido un gars
très brillant très articulé on a
vraiment aimé le savoir ph
on est tous les deux fans mais ph est
particulièrement fan de lui ça va rester
notre podcast a fait vraiment longtemps
que j'écoute larry kilman que d'un point
de vue littéraire chaud que ces textes
sont vraiment un autre niveau
c'est un peu de rap game au québec j'ai
toujours trouvé que larry qu'elle était
un artiste qui me fascinait puis ça a
été un honneur de le rencontrer puis de
pouvoir poser toutes les questions qui
me brûlait les lèvres depuis vraiment
longtemps fait vraiment une conversation
sur paris chante avec éclat riz avec le
jeune homme lui même si vous écoutez
présentement sur
balade dos les signaux writing laissez
nous un commentaire
si vous écoutez sur balles à dos écoutez
pas le prochain message qui suit parce
que si vous écoutez sur youtube sachez
que vous pouvez nous écouter seulement
en audio fait calme et on vous êtes sur
la go vous êtes au jam vous êtes dans
l'auto vous êtes en train de faire la
cuisine pour nous écouter seulement en
audio sur soi sport f1 soit
l'application podcast vous avez un
apport soit google play soit iron will
go on et sur toutes ces affaires le fait
que si vous voulez changer aux habitudes
de consommation de podcasts je vous
encourage à le faire ou sinon et
contenus sur youtube puis ça nous fait
aussi plaisir de vous avoir à chaque
semaine surtout si vous laissez des
commentaires si vous participez à la
discussion si vous abonner à notre
chaîne
tout ça nous a donné un gros coup de
main et sans plus attendre
on me soutenaient sans qu'on voie ce
sens que les wicked bompas de caste
bonne écoute
[Musique]
jeune homme est la viking yes man mersey
sera prise sera pris un certain temps
wen à mâcon mais qu'elle a à peine
tardinghen occupée ouais je te récup et
je le suis toujours je vais l'être
jusqu'au fait moi comme un atout mais
ces sommes c'est la vie mais c'est la
vie je vois ça descend directement
choisis c'est la vie que j'ai fait c'est
quoi ton auto blick acquis au sol un peu
ça c'est quoi ton nom mais laurent l'a
gentiment appelé jean vieil homme
vieirinha s'éveillant tt donne avec les
jeunes
non non non non c'est toujours jeune
homme sait d'où ça vient semaine jeunes
en a moins je crois que ça vide
je crois que ça vient vraiment de djezzy
qui criait comme violent au début c'est
au début ses raps wayne young jeezy
aussi je trouve ça vraiment intéressant
puisque juste comme adapté en français
puis la sonorité puis l'espèce de 12 ans
maintenant quand tu entends jeune homme
juste avant 20 heures
c'est précisément que c'est moi qui
m'arrive c'est comme le mazembe
ça annonce bien lovers ces annonces
précisément le jardin de l'actuelle on
est loin de ouais c'est quand l'entente
fait craquer yayi comme les lois ne
soient que le chapeau mais surtout
djezzy était à tout le temps son pion il
s'en vient dans la grille c'est ça fait
effectivement une bonne culture de la
jamais vu demande n'avait jamais pu même
réfléchir étrangement de comme un espèce
de pingouins qui revient tout le temps
tu ton nom depuis les tout débuts de ta
carrière de rapports non non
cet entraînement quoi les humiliant kate
kate ont détruit personnes a tout de
suite appelé big boss man ray puis c'est
ptet pas c'était pas du tout quelque
chose qui avait un rapport avec mon
orgueil solide pour les game brown qui
savent peut-être de quoi je parle
mais c'était juste et ça c'était il y
avait ce sens j'ai eu ce n'est plus tant
que ça à vrai dire bah c'est peut-être
un des bas c'est bon c'est vrai oui
c'est bon c'est assez gênant pour 600
jeunes surtout comme quand tu
considérablement en début de carrière
comme at&t pas décemment big boss non
vraiment pas un mais
même on n'était même pas sur les tanks
ont commencé à rapper à l'époque c'est
vraiment drôle non voulait vraiment
passé ouais ouais moi puis la piste est
c'était c'était quoi c'était un cours
d'école
c'était ouais bah c'était comme
secondaire 1 ou 2 à peu près on se
montrait nos cahiers avec nous nous
appuyons sur ligne aile heerema la fin
laisse alors la syllabe en mai cfoot
c'est nous autres on avait des gars qui
qui rappelle un des gars qui rappe aux
seconds ap
c'est tout le monde comme une histoire
de guerre qui rappe au seconde armée de
gueux qui rappe au secondaire qui crise
qui continue à rapide qui finalement
m'est kate moss histoire il arrive
quelques passes ouais ouais je sais pas
j'ai pas l'impression que c'est une
affaire une affaire de persévérance
fortement gêné affaire de chance un peu
dans la mesure où si j'ai l'impression
qu'ils apprennent du rappeur à mon
second d'argent qu'ils allaient
probablement pu continuer puis être
superbe on le sait aussi puisque un
manège et tu vois pas ne soit pas une
opportunité ou quoi que ce soit puisse
se lâche mais ces gens-là rémy peut-être
le même effort que moi ou qui sait où il
serait à rim est urgent besoin
le talent il n'est quelques profs ça
dépend juste que mon seul façonne qu'ils
pensent mais ton et si quoi tu entends
nombreuses chansons mettant dans seul
tu m'étonnes que tu dis qu'un aspect de
chance et ou qui a eu un break
toi tu quelque chose que quelqu'un
d'autre et paul mettons
je veux dire on s'est fait remarquer on
s'est fait remarquer par index appelé
julien qui s'appelle toujours lui qui
nous a comme un peu ouvert les portes de
l'industrie et tout ça mais j'imagine
que ça relève pas tant de la chance
finalement maintenant qu'il expose comme
ça c'est juste comme le talent qui
ultime mais sauce comme enjeu le moi
j'ai le tendance à penser que si tu fais
quelque chose qui est sacoche
ça va trouver quelqu'un comme j'étais au
target tout le monde dit c'est vraiment
une question de contacts puis je
comprends que l'industrie est une
industrie de ses pires des contacts
certains n'ont que dotons pas par contre
on dirait qu on dirait que peut-être
naïvement j'ai l'impression se fait
quelque chose qui est de la bombe même
quelqu'un vole en france presque
naïvement puis un versement tu peux
avoir des contacts d'atr piètre le pro
des pilleurs s'il tarde à un pool house
la proposition artistique et pour rennes
st marc peau ça allait proposer
mais de nos jours de plus en plus aussi
les gens sont à la recherche de
contenant et moins de contenu des faits
que je crois que je crois que la lure la
lourde quelqu'un ou tout son emballage
avec lequel il peut se présenter à
n'importe qui qui est de l'influencé
puis que des contacts peut l'amener
quelques passes mode où je viens où se
douche bien ou avec du moins le pourquoi
qu'on s'est fait connaître
c'est très certainement à cause de ce
qu'on faisait puis pas de ce qu'on
dégage mais le fait ce qu'on dégage est
aussi un ultime en beaucoup aidé mais
c'était passé notre notre notre
réflexion et potes n'étaient pas du tout
le temps je faisais je comprends bien
d'accord avec toi j'ai vraiment
l'impression qu'en ce moment le tout le
branding autour de l'artiste autour de
la musique y aussi sinon plus important
qu'est la musique en tant que tel c'est
fait remarquer plus à cause de ton
branding plus le team hm ça s'avère que
tu es super bombe vers les étoiles
salling nous avons fait remarquer mais
aussi que les gens s'identifient t à une
esthétique aussi autant que de la
musique loops non plus me
c'est à travers ce taux grimpe à travers
les vidéos clips
la musique est bonne les personnes qui
s'intéressent à ce qui est des guerres
personnes en juin c'est une nouvelle
c'est une nouvelle approche qui sait
comment disait c'est pas quelque chose
que je reproche c'est quelque chose que
j'observe c'est plutôt quelque chose qui
n'est pas quelque chose qui me fait
chier ou quoi que ce soit c'est juste
c'est comme ça maintenant est ce que est
ce que toi tu t'en celui-ci dans tous
parlent de l'apparence en général a dû
du branding comme tel ouais quand même
énormément
non mais moi j'ai forcément puisque je
sais ce que je fais aussi dans la vie
d'une marque de vêtement fait que la
direction artistique l'esthétique c'est
quelque chose qui me c'est quelque chose
qui me dont je me soucie beaucoup mais
reste que c'est plus en ce qui concerne
toit par recherche de dubeau - ou plus
par par direction artistique face à la
réception du public me tombe
je pense même que ce nom et non annoncés
accès enfin c'est très précis il faut
faire la part des choses parce que si tu
veux si tu veux juste partir sur ton
propre très participent puisque l'idée
c'est que si tu veux faire passer un
message le jeu ne faut pas qu'il faut
que tu faut quand même que tu plies est
ce que les gens risquent d'écouter un
peu de gens d'affaires
je sais poste ces passeurs on ne sait
pas se prostituer aussi pas vendre son
âme ou quoi que ce soit c'est joseph
puisque ma nes et d'un artiste veut dire
quelque chose des choses à dire si
c'était si situe pas sur un trait
participe je fais des chansons album de
chansons besides sans refrain avec
diverses de 8 minutes de saint paul
genre de pièce de théâtre je disais
comme je peux repartir sur un gros
traits passé comme ça mais joseph
s'appelait un mini cercle de gens
fake mais ce n'est même pas tout est dit
comme je l'expliqué le principe de cet
extrait ce que je pense que mon intérêt
pour la direction artistique qui le
l'esthétisme
c'est juste de faire la part des choses
en ce que je veux profondément puisque
ce que ce que les gens risquent de bien
vouloir accepter de moi tu sais pas
cependant c'est pas de vouloir tant leur
plaire mais c'est juste d'être d'être
concis à skier quand consommables un
digest
je pensais aussi d'être sensible à l'art
du temps aussi le but était de vouloir
se poser la question qu'est ce que les
gens aient envie d'entendre ses pensées
aussi je te demandais qui c'est quoi
c'est quoi qui dans l'art c'est que les
sujets chauds c'est quoi c'est que les
sujets de conversation sur un litige jeu
se plier un comment se plie à vendre
avant des stands up y avoir des parents
m quand tu fais de la musique le sait
très bien
c'est très bien ça te force à te sortir
de ta jambe par des choix sans
nécessairement mais voilà c'est comme
des paramètres de de temps pour composer
des paramètres de temps dans une chanson
des paramètres ou tu t'imposes de
refrains tu t'imposes de refrains
d'intel de tel nombre de bornes
versata s'approchait ça pour chasser
d'être con c'est assez d'être créatif on
va quelque chose que tu avais peut-être
pas fait comme ça puis ce que je m'en
vais là dessus parce que les gars avec
qui j'ai travaillé pour l'album rohff et
just c'est gai qui comprennent super
bien la musique 1 1
très haut niveau si c'est des gars qui
ont une grande oreille gros soleil wege
avec les plus grosses des faits qui
m'ont ils m'ont ils m'ont vraiment bien
guidés à travers l'album puis ça a été
extrêmement intéressant de retravailler
ma façon de faire qui était pas du tout
dans un espèce de cadres pas commercial
maison
ouais j'aime bien le mot digest toi
parce que même si tu es même si prend
quelqu'un si je dis toi c'est pas parce
que on te propose un cadre qui plus
restreint que toi tu va nécessairement
changer la façon que tu approches l'or
non non c'est ton écriture python rap et
too fake
effectivement si on écouté l'album
thriller sus matin il fait qu'on n'a pas
eu le temps de l'écouté vraiment en
profondeur mais sait on est on est pas
où est ce qu'on est et avec contrôle non
non c'est c les bêtes sont plus digeste
sauf que toi ton son ton énergie et
demeure la wii qui demain c'est
certainement moins sombre somme toute
que contrôle mais je disais ça reste
c'est attendre juillet youpi 12
saint-amand pas comme ça mais parce que
c'est pas comme ça que je suis en fait
j'ai comme sa vie mais pas celle-là
c'est ça la fin et b celle dans la vie
mais pas en musique j'aime bien ma
musique tristan fin mai
fake wee cc c'est autre chose ce
contrôle s'est plus comment dire c'est
plus grand public c'est plus la scc
beaucoup plus réfléchi aussi contre onze
c'est beaucoup plus réfléchi sur sur
lequel il est écrit des refrains 116 sur
cet album l'appui puis c'est un exercice
demandant mais excessivement le fun city
puis à pas comme une ligne qui ai pas
réfléchi comme trois fois 6 albums
l'agencé vendu c'était pas le cas sur
qu'on voit sur son contrôle c'était
juste une paire de ma vie où ça allait
pas vraiment bien je lisais de la
littérature vraiment sombre et
pessimiste école puis je buvais
énormément puis je souhaite un album
comme en six mois le terrain j'ai écrit
comme ken chanson en six mois jean
vraiment sans vraiment aucune direction
ainsi d'ajuster pitch est ce que
j'avance dedans puis gelé comme je le
dis tout ça c'était très exigeant
soit ouah c'est un très petit je
joindrai loin de regretter contrôle
genre contrats des fois je réécoute le
la cohésion d'install bommel est
incroyable j'avais adoré embarqué dans
une intrigue vraiment semble s'en être
servi sans parler c'est justement
l'exercice de concision sur les taux
nous on le voit les toons checker la jac
l'espi sont somme toute assez courtes la
plupart justement temps prévenait
extrait sait comment battre trois
minutes puis la tonne philips est comme
il est je finis mais est ce si l'intro
de l'album et enfin à mon avis c'est les
gars qui ont décidé seul dans les trous
tout commence immédiatement puis tire la
plogue ça finit direct piscicole mais
des fois des tchèques de même c'est
comme la tonne fini pis t'as le goût de
l'art mais tais-toi déjà donné dort
jamais assez c'est come back et encore
une fois c'est clairement une réflexion
que c'était quoi c'était quoi
est-ce que l'énergie était différent
maintenant dans le processus de
recording des créations avec entre les
deux albums où va mais quand même
beaucoup dans ça a été beaucoup plus
organique le deuxième album jeudi le
premier album c'est juste moi qui ai
écrit un peu dans mon coin pendant un
très peu de temps puis enregistrer ici
et là avec 20 des lobbies aussi belle
aussi des lobbies j'ai eu des super bons
moments avec valse mais c'est un album
qui s'est fait un peu en deux parties
soit jean moi et lui en suisse soit jeu
mais larry texte d'abord les beats sont
arrivés après non non non je vais agir
sur les bee gees libye sauf que si je
dois y a pas eu de commandes faisait pas
nécessairement de ben voilà avec avec
vais bien évidemment on a jasé ici et là
du point de vue musical mais c'est jeudi
le tout le contenu ça relevait que deux
mois fait que je les fais de montbard
ensuite j'ai quand même j'ai enregistré
sa piscine ça fait ce truc c'est bon
mais pour ce qui est de rome
je dis les gars j'enregistrais
j'enregistrais comme douze mesures je
l'envoyais au games est ce qu'on passe
un ordre il faisait un peu des reals
dessus il ya eu beaucoup de ça a été
super organique on s'est vraiment
consultée pour tout tout tout j'ai pris
j'ai pris énormément de critiques de
leurs papilles de bonnes critiques
justes c'est très challenger noir crois
que c'est vraiment ça la différence de
l'implication de toute l'équipe
enfin même de gabes puis clément les
gars chez qui j'ai enregistré qui ont
été jean vraiment l'eau tout le temps
puis qu'ils donnaient leur avion studio
lahoud m'a beaucoup on a beaucoup
échangé des idées avec la fecq
je voulais pas non plus garder ça pour
moi je voulais pas d'un an
d'un homme écouté toutes les chansons
ici comme au fur et à mesure que ça se
faisait si j'avais j'avais évidemment je
ne faisais pas entendre à qui mieux
mieux ça mais j'avais j'avais juste un
siècle de gendre comme de confiance avec
qui on a balancé plein d'idées tout au
long on a quand même eu un semi luxe de
temps cette fois ci c'est un an et demi
près mais ouais je sais bien si je
disais quand je pense que des fouilles
album qui peuvent se faire aussi on a eu
on a eu le temps des tirs un peu la
chose serait très bien soit est ce
qu'elle à la genèse du projet cette
rencontre et puis ça fait à qui la
direction ça va être le son ça va être
plus de français où ça se trouve ça se
trouve au fur et à mesure cela fasse x
ou comme je veux sommes tout de même
c'est quand même un gros album de rap
c'est évidemment sur thème qui est sûre
hommes et de leur team jamais c'est très
large de rompre en parlais tantôt mais
je sais très large ne sais pas c'est
comme un album de rap agences comme un
gros album doha gens qui qui traite de
tout et de rien mais match il y vraiment
je peux je peux je peut diminuer sans la
en lisant comme ça mais c'est ça que
c'est pas si c'est presque il ya une
chanson deux clubs d'une chanson de
chaud une chanson c'est pas seulement
sont à notre sens est pas de se
reconnaissaient pas d'éloges à beaucoup
de chair sur les os n'est plus seulement
la la mais je veux dire que ne s'est pas
des têtes d'intellectualiser sodoku
c'est la substance l'analyse et de
l'inde
s'il ya bien une cohésion dans l'album
c'est celle que jean le
et tous les beats sont de la même gang
qui sont sont finement travaillé et
étudié dans l'ordre dans lesquels on
vous les présente
mais les sujets savent sa voix à droite
à gauche
c'est vrai l'album de toile c'est parce
qu'ils transportent
c'est l'album loud tour neeson qui ont
chacun des six avait coûté vous écoutez
monsieur bruit la peine de l'ex alors ce
n'est pas après pg honnêtement très
écouté très attentivement et moi à
première écoute les genres de beats
surtout la première claque
si sur la première séparation des genres
de beats sur le dernier album des
menaces le produit par kanye west le
chipeau si je sais pas si je l'écoutais
pas la bande-annonce casabonne des
bouches et y voit non absolument c'est
un petit détour s'impose petit à petit
un gros truc la seule espèce 2010 cas
c'est le genre est presque gosselin et
ça ça laisse beaucoup de place à la voix
est d'ouvrir quand même quelque chose
d'extrêmement ccc l'album ouvrage que je
sais ce que je sais pas c'est quoi les
appelations je connais pas assez le rap
pour ça me fait ça me fait beaucoup
penser effectivement les derniers albums
de cagnes et papa dernier dernier les
derniers bilans des banques
un peu plus tard mais quelque chose à
gré agressif sans sentir agressif je
sais pas c'est peut-être pas là le terme
non mais il ya quelque chose de mon avis
est quelque chose dans mon album qui est
sans prétention évidemment mais quelque
chose d'un peu de temps à me laisse dans
dans la mesure où on a surfé sur un
karim a juste surfer sur réjean on n'a
pas dit quand on avait des beats de
d'inspiration peut-être devrait faire
quelque chose qui rend ma sosa mais
finalement les élections finissait par
être loin tout autre fake sur l'analyse
de toutes les chansons que c'est comme
si je faisais rien comme tu peux voir le
faire des liens ici l'homme sait rien de
réfléchi
justement je fais et je sais c'est le
sacrifierait exactement cepici paye ya
aucun aucun instructeur andy gens je te
connais tu sois frais gens réfléchis tu
dit
et puis des gros crescendo dans les
chansons pour que le monde dans les
shows comme l'y pousse pousse finalement
se battre on écoute et une belle fusion
sa montre mais justement c'est mettons
la deuxième c'est dans le clip est comme
de joakim noah c'est la deuxième partie
jeux télé jan fabre haute cour mais en
même temps ce poser aux colliers comme
des cristaux de 9 pi d'être au bac a en
même temps ça c'est vraiment cinéma vol
mais évidemment absent il enlève ça même
si je parle déjà 120 parce que c'est son
beat g sont vite que une fois que
ressentent pas si sûr
c'est lui qui met tous les mets tout les
élans plutôt plus et mode ses frais de
réalisation dans les chansons quand tu
entends un silence quand tu entends une
espèce de
un autre piano comment les comment il
fait
c'est le crémage ou enlever des affaires
comme la police anti redondant soins qui
est grave ça suffit
fake puis parce que c'est un bide déjà
ce puits
c'est très propre et déjà ce genre de la
prochaine ça sonne au secours comme tu
dis mais pourtant est quelque chose qui
visiblement les audiblement ce n'est pas
de penser c'est comme juste retraité
traiter le symptôme genre mais avec une
avec une touche gens super moderne
puisque tu le décrivent comme ça que
j'ai senti que j'ai entendu c'est un
vrai qu il ya beaucoup de gestes ça
faisait longtemps que j'avais hâte
d'avoir une conversation avec toi parce
que beaucoup de personnes qui s'est fait
flasher un peu une culture artistique
mettons danville et si quelqu'un qui va
prendre une photo et est en train de
lire dostoïevski alors que c'est c'est
le premier nom quelqu'un va d'europe et
quand on parle de l'état littérature
russe lancé comme des certains
classiques et mettons moi j'aime
vraiment solaire j'ai lu l'alchimiste de
paulo coelho alors que comme le go to
que tout le monde vous dira que c'est
facile de flash et avoir l'air de
s'intéresser alors pour l'heure où livre
tellement de la sphère fokine hermétique
mais jacques et ses claques était sur
tous les outils pour comprendre ce que
je fis centre j'avais hâte de parler
avec toi parce que chez pour un fait que
toi c'est loin d'être sûr parce qu'il en
est je le rappelle tom wolfe est mort
non ton move c'est le père du nouveau
journalisme j'ai fait ben zekri sur
l'apport intéresse thompson c'était lui
l'autre auteur qu'elle faisait ma
maîtrise et sa différence entre les deux
c'est la drogue
pratiquement
pierre pitié si je veux dire tant mieux
si tu connais ton bois puis tout au
courant qu'ils mangent te sais pas c'est
pas de la petite heure c'est pas du
bonbon laisse pas quelque chose que tout
le monde connaît puisque quelque chose
que tout le monde peut s'intéresser
mais que fait que je vois toutes
partagent comme une photo de tom wolfe
dans son complet blanc récemment mais
moi je fais comme omagad c'est
clairement et pose cette photo-là pas
parce qu'ils trouvent que la haute
futaie nice le aujourd'hui de tout les
jours n'étaient plus après cette sortie
ne tourne que tu avais écrit web ac /
tom butler et écoutons mouche
nécessairement mais le refrain message
il ya les coachs et lui remet la gauche
qui a bien fait mais je le nomme anglais
j'ai pas lu non c'est quoi ça prend des
rares écologique c'est la gauche caviar
celui qui a comme c'est lui que comme
amener cette espèce de termes la css de
concept là on august rendez en
illustrant des des familles blanches
juive riche dans les années soixante dix
qui tenaient des des levées de fonds
pour les blagues plein mais je veux dans
le dans la réception il y avait des
avait déjà fait des blacks
il y avait des mères du black
distribuait de ce que c'était comme une
espèce de gros de grossesse
contradictions en contradictions enfin
d'où sa part peut-être moi mais enfin
fake je trouve ça juste intéressant de
faire un lien avec ça parce que bas les
coaches xtet je trouvais juste pour son
juste pour son habillement en blanc et
tout ça puis enfin je me compare à lui
de rage en disant que juste comme je
suis un con traire vivant
certes mais aussi que juste comme fois
kenwyne avis mais c'est souvent le cas
des parts et le chef d'enquêté quelque
chose d'autre quelque chose d'autre le
derrière
derrière le rap derrière lui
le l'intérêt alors il ya un intérêt réel
ouais ouais mais je je je j'ai le regret
je le regrette vraiment que je lis très
peur maintenant je sais pas si je sais
pas si c'est juste ma vie
professionnelle gens qui a pris trois à
l'euro 2000 sont moches mais je savais
qu'en venant ici on allait probablement
jaser de littératie 3 1% mais non mais
non bien agissent avec jacques grand
respect désormais je me jetais comme
metge c'est quelque chose je lis presque
plus et je lis presque plus un gilet
presque plus j'ai peine à feuilleter un
magazine de mode jean vraiment qu'est ce
que tu consommes en ce moment que marché
kt est souvent souvent partage des trucs
par rapport aux beaux-arts d de fast
food et de la loi c'est moi je suis
beaucoup je suis beaucoup de deux
comptes de design d'intérieur de
beaucoup de petites galeries tout ça
fait que sam sam nourrissait mais ouais
mais ces jeux
ça fait vraiment longtemps j'ai que j'ai
ouvert un livre je sais que quelqu'un
comme deux trois mois j'ai ouvert j'ai
ouvert la tentation d'exister de seraing
pour me remettre ces j'ai fait quand
c'est pas genre de livre que tu peux
très bien il faut sur comment cela veut
dire à l'époque même j'aurai je sais que
fut un temps où j'aurai comme passer une
après-midi à surligner déchets tard lire
des passages a aimé l'espèce de
challenge intellectuel que j'avais de
liège puis on dirait que je sais pas si
moment de l'est maintenant c'est juste
des dirigeants ccc faut une bonne
rigueur manne pour cultiver l'intellect
surtout à rodez jean chapeau à tous les
gens qui
[Musique]
yamato move c'est ce titre move temps
c'est un érudit mais des érudits comme
ceux il y en a plus tant que seul ouais
mais qui qui qui consacre sa vie à lui
je lui étais c'était comme moi c'était
comme un c'est comme un intellectuel
vraiment au sens propre puis j'ai qui au
sens propre et au sens radical radicale
mais cette quête intellectuelle est le
plus jeune ma tante le fait plus jeunes
ou ben oui puis sauf que parce que juste
entre les intérêts ont toujours été
intellectuels comme moi je suis pas un
intellectuel je crois pas avoir assez de
connaissances pour l'algérie puis je
crois pas je crois peu surtout avoir un
point de vue précis sur beaucoup de
choses
je ferai pas s'il faudrait pas prendre
je pourrai pas débattre profondément
d'un sujet donné
c'est donc c'est un intellectuel je
pense qu'il faut que tu ailles
feuilleton d'opinion qu'il faut que tu
puisses lalala défendit dans la
rhétorique pour baptiste jon et erich
puis faut que tu es un bon bagage de
connaissances et pourtant et souvent ça
vient cacher je peux pas ce que j'ai lu
beaucoup de trucs de philo puis que j'ai
lu des livres d'espionnage puis j'ai lu
depuis
puis j'ai lu deux journalistes j'aime
bien en jaser sur ce que je peut jaser
de jusque jean-jacques dans mes chansons
c'est fake de l'aude de l'intérêt dans
de mort par les après dans une entrevue
que de voir jusqu'où ça va mais si ces
statues l'intellectuel louis vi vient
souvent avec et des études le jeudi 6 1
6 voilà tous les cas mais si mais si m
c'est vrai mais c'est les gens qu'on
attend sur la place publique le débat
très des sujets de société
dtcc c'est rarement les autres des pur
autodidacte non plus n'ont jamais servi
un petit peu ce que tu dis c'est quand
ta vie professionnelle prend tellement
de place pour pouvoir cultiver sur faut
que ça soit ta vie professionnelle exact
loin ou assez cocasses ou que nous
quittons moment off c'est que tu ton
cerveau il tente pas ces gens je suis
pas sûr que je vais pas sûr que ça peut
être un moment off comme ça qu'on peut
cultiver l'intellectuel dans un réel
moment au nom mais vous non merci ça que
je te dis c'est que jantes et même avec
même avec la fatigue et tout ça qu'on se
rentre à la maison tu dis est faux que
hagard équipé gouvenement maïs ogm est
un cadran puis je dois le bookeen et une
api césaire ce que je disais que je me
rappelle à l'université fallait je lis
prochain épisode d'hubert aquin qui est
un chef-d'oeuvre la littérature
québécoise pour la première phrase c'est
cuba cole en flammes au fond du lac
léman alors que je descends au fond des
choses
puis je me rappelle que j'avais ouvert
le livre j'ai dû se la première phrase
glisseurs les faits alors mais non mais
c'est sûr puis je les ferme et j'ai fait
pas aujourd'hui il faut que ce soit
parce que le jeu peut pas mettre
là-dedans pire venir quoi que ce soit de
ce qui va se passer dans la prochaine
peut pas mettre là-dedans maintenant
j'en remets toi quand tu dois être moins
fatigués prêt à la longère et ce au
cinéroc j'ai souvent fait justement me
lancer dans des oeuvres juste trop aride
ou trop dans un mauvais moment où juste
juste et étaient propres et si tu veux
si tu vas marquer la littérature
commencé d'equity sauf de facile que
nous aimer est un phare et abritera tout
ce n'est pas un show tableau
si ça ça t'amène vers des livres des
livres de le building romane
c'est comme des livres croissance
personnelle avant la croissance
personnelle alchimie dans le fond c'est
des livres comme cela qu'ils font à
prendre surtout à pitre si tu veux te
lancer dans ce commence par l'alchimiste
c'est vraiment la bonne place pour
commencer
ça dépend par tous d'un possible si
genre commence par l'effort de la
fontaine au pire je commence pas de quoi
déjà le tpiy mais c'est une bonne base
peut-être juste les rangs soit c'est
bien ce qui est souvent boudé stephen
king c'est excellent aucune raison de
douter c'est incroyable et les nouvelle
de stephen king peuvent être une
alternative quand ton cerveau est un
cépage vraiment un hall pour les gens là
oui on assume on a reçu patrick senécal
sur le podcast sont ils aussi en est que
il ya un peu la même aura que stephen
king
il va être boudée par la haute sphère la
littérature mais en même temps stephen
qui réalise et dudu patrick senécal sait
combien de jeunes intéressés à la
lecture c'est ça aussi c'est que la
version trash sexuellement desprat
vidalies exact mais ouais je crois que
je crois que j'étais peut-être un peu
dans ce top six mois avec parce que
c'est les adaptations de ses films sont
semi de ces jeux mais j'ose croire que
ces livres sont très bien c'est aller
sur seconde actes sont leurs 4 tout le
monde l'avait c'est bon là c'est bien
mais c'est parfait mais j'ai bien aimé
quand même le séjour du talion le film
et que le fumier bien vouloir aimer
c'est parce que passer avec claude
legault
dacca - ci afin dé bonnes fondateur sur
le dit frédéric way grosse photographies
de biens durables laisser ces gens ne ti
sont importantes et puis comme dans
n'importe quelle heure tu t'embarques
bergman outil va commencer par tarantino
tombé l'an dernier c'est parfait puis
moussa était sur mon parcours commencé
que tarantino piscicole ok ça peut être
un peu différent ça peut être
puis la pression dit m curieux du pilote
le tout même heure même affaire que tu
commences pas écouté genre du black
metal norvégien même quand il commence à
écouter du black metal l'esprit que je
suis calme ans avec du qg du candidat
presque plus et enfin 2 mais tout s'est
tu sais que c'est toi tu en parles en t
il ya beaucoup la culture de bâtir ton
d'aleg cible mais là je parle je parle
pas de tendre tantôt oratoire menant
rappelé bon total aig et si ton succès
email à email
le floch un petit pipi hmm hmm l'arda
certains égards c'est c'est au tour du
titre du hem du top qui sait comment au
top pipi maintenant je suis rendu au top
mais je comprends syncup on le sait que
c'est exact l'espèce de culture mais il
ya beaucoup beaucoup de ça dans le rap
puis quand j'écoute ce que toi tu fais
ça je te dis que j'ai hâte de retourner
chez nous que d'écouter
et encore le nouvel album on retrouve
sur un peu mais pas tant que ça mais
merci mais je pense que pour être très
honnête je fais aussi pratiquement que
c'est juste que si tu le cites il décèle
potence et je le fait d'une bonne façon
à ma façon
je me vois autant qu'un autre a passé je
fait je fais la même qu'aux parades sur
le même comparatif que l'on fera pas
partie de rire on dit juste que je
m'enferme je le fais vraiment ma façon
qui est à travers même et tu vois tu
vois je pas d'accord mais je pense que
oui parce que j'ai l'impression que ces
serrures que tu entendes mène un rapport
rapper sur le fait que l'eau tabarnak
puis j'ai voulu moi j'ai voulu - pour
reprendre les mots met un terme à ma vie
il est chez nous autant temps de repos
semaine tu entendras pas c'était quoi et
met en fête à mine sur les sur la liste
d'exemples de loin
c'est cette semaine dans ton post saison
aux dépens des bons exemples
ces contrôles se font contrôler
effectivement j'ai exploré des années 20
sur et abanda tall la traque
on est comme arrêter de parler pour le
fait que cela arrive
et comme plus l'eau le barcelone ouais
ouais ouais mais tu sais c'est que c'est
en bonne voie non mais c'était tout à
fait le tout à fait bon mais c'est que
tu as me semble me sens je trouve ça
rafraîchissant parce que c'est un jeu
c'est pas que je sais pas comment
expliquer ça mais tant que je prends mon
exemple la moitié peas est à des années
lumières de de ce que toi tu peux v ou
de ce que la levée de ce que ce que des
rapports qui réussissent pouvez-vous des
musiciens qui réussissent moi mettons
d'accéder à un certain niveau de fin
août ces deux
le avec le podcast de respect outils de
l'espèce des niveaux des aplombs surf
est ce ça vient avec un esti de backlash
aussi puis il pas un jour de ma vie où
est ce que je ne rêvais pas me disant
est-ce que je changerais sur pour
revenir à mon anonymat
est-ce que je changerais ça pour revenir
à juste pas avoir toute cette pression
le site ce regard là du public sept à
être sur ce piédestal que les gens
peuvent se déposer
il n'y a pas un jour de ma vie parce que
je me pose pas la question ce que je
serai mieux si j'étais paul
moi ce que je serai mieux s'y jeter en
bas c'est puis je peux comprendre que
pour beaucoup de monde je pourrais
prendre exemple de 6e qui dit moi mon
rêve c'est d'être sur un bateau il ya du
monde que c'est ça le rêve qui
arrêterons pas avant d'être rendu
l'appui que plus ça grossit plus l'
empire grossit plus en bien mais c'est
pas vrai que c'est tout le monde puis
j'aime / comme cette espèce de de dire à
qui mène le jeu rendu l'âme et voici
aussi ce que ça peut faire
je pense pas qu'on l'entend beaucoup je
pense pas même qu'on l'entend c'est ce
que souvent si glorifier ces affaires là
justement je parle beaucoup les
messieurs mais elisabeth riou dans
l'indien qui était en voyage tout le
temps mieux le monde font comme roque 6e
mais elisabeth même là bien faire
dernièrement impôt social à part être
des fois pendant une semaine j'ai pas le
temps de prendre la douche
george est pas le temps m'a
littéralement gpat 2g crise pendant
genre deux mois sa maison à l'épaule
meublent leur work de ces deux de ces
gens là et est indéniable est indéniable
mais
oui je trouve que je trouve qu'ils ont
on donne on donne beaucoup le on parle
beaucoup du rêve puis là l'aboutissement
sans vraiment parler du chemin petit
boulot que ça prend une idée de ce que
ça peut amener aussi têtu revoir la
médaille que ça peut amener je trouve
que toi tu le fais mettons nous moi pis
toi je pense qu'on est on parle aussi
d'un point de vue du monde qui ont pas
mangé de la mare de l'été commencé
d'armes et a grandi avec une cuillère
d'argent gratuit avec une croix d'argent
dans la bouche pitié on commence cette
culture là dans le rap ça vient ça vient
pas de nulle part le saviez kittila plus
port la plupart des rapports aux états
unis viennent de milieux très difficile
très défavorisé de rien eu un et deux
options se fait de la musique souvent
d'adopter peas n'ont put it on a mis ces
fêtes chute la semaine passée et puis
c'est ça la réalité c'est fake de la
fierté de mérite pour les autres
j'ai l'impression que les textes ou de
se sortir facilement explicable
exactement les épis table a justement
d'où ils viennent puis comment ils ont
grandi mais l'idée de montrer leur
revers de tout ça c'est pas je ne sais
pas pourquoi c'est à mon avis c'est
juste moi je prends je prends plaisir à
le faire même si ces chansons là sont
excessivement gens tristes mais c'est
pas mon métier je pense que je pense que
la horde des très bons des très bonnes
lignes par rapport au revard soit là
aussi
ouais je sais pas pour citer mon boyle
mélenchon pour qui je crois qu'ils s'y
prend très bien aussi mais
ouais c'est évidemment josé le commander
l espèce de personnages puis l'espèce
deux espèces de brevard aucun album de
rap
or il peut perdre selon le rappeur
donner un peu de crédibilité si
justement il se met à être un peu trop
sensible par rapport à lui-même ce sens
et que c'est peut-être pour ça que c'est
très rarement vu comme ça mais en même
temps je puis en disant je pense à joy
qui a toujours été très très ouvert sur
ses hauts ses bas ses sentiments je
pense que ça ça paraît dans dans le rap
d'aujourd'hui en général tout simplement
définitivement et aux états unis a lancé
son album aventis idée swimming ci a
tourné beaucoup autour de succès mais je
n'y allais pas bien moins 30 ans là
dessus mais je sais pas j'ai comme
l'impression qu'au québec il vraiment
pas cet aspect
parce que le rap est pas encore rendus
sceptiques il faut que le rap fluctue à
se rendre vraiment aux puits après saw
this way
une astuce d'ouverture puis une métier
c'est d'autre part l'émotivité jack
parce qu'on a reçu les louanges ces pays
afin qu'ils y avaient finale bolt sait
pas ce que c'est par rapp métis ça
flirte avec m c'est pire il parlait de
son real c'est bon qu'on fait mais oui
l'aller les filles aiment ça les gars
qui qui chantera pas un pub qui part de
leur émotion et oui ça va marcher
ouais mais il ya vraiment il y aura une
couleur serment qui a fait et puis il
est exploité un style qui ne s'était pas
fait et on sent que ce n'est pas fait
encore ici en france et un chapeau
c'est un break et je parle de mon
honnêteté drake
non même en été il tape à sercus aux
médecins pas encore complètement à rémy
la non mais c'est rien d'extravagant
c'est juste j'ai brossé
j'ai vécu mort que justement pire comme
ta vie de 8 à 12 ans nous parle à un
étage afin de tester brûlé ici c'est pas
pour moi c'est super tu vois comme les
reflex j'ai vu la bière léger voulu
l'ouvrir directement mais plus loin de
six mois sans alcool c'est juste pour
dire que lui cet été charles est à deux
semaines brest deux semaines mais non
elle laisse monter la tension
mais beaucoup d'alcool ou non mais non
c'était avait beaucoup avant quand même
quand même je pourrais définitivement
ouais non il n'y a pas eu de façon de
dire je vois que mes pensées les
pragmatiques non belges de ces
problématiques pour pi c'est aussi
simple que ce c'est que le lendemain
mène tout ce que tu paies rageux son
envie de le voir a juste à vivre ton ton
regret ni comment ça pète jean une
brosse logis 31 ans c'est vraiment peur
qu'avant c'est sale ça là comme aucun
bon sens quel point un supporter ce
genre
et puis je veux qu'en limitant à cette
page
les ateliers du ciel les arrêts de jeu
ma blonde la gérante est quand même qui
vient me voir pour que je vais prendre
démersales arrête pas là que j'ai envie
de vomir par une journée plus mourir
c'est une ville tout son sens quand même
c'est juste c'est la vraie nuisance de
ce live talent c'est juste ramasser le
lendemain lancé puis tu vois tous les
gens je connais qui qui qui cela que
jean pour vrai leur productivité et
quand elle est décuplée mais ce soir
c'est fou ces os il ya tout près
davantage à ce lac et ses avantages
notamment sur le temps du gang
ce ton portefeuille qu il veut parler
des brasseries bars le soir après soir
le savent bien qu'ils aient exécution le
fomc avait pris ça en même temps même un
effet vraiment beaucoup d'avantagés mais
là de faire l'éloge de la gueule si
justement la peau humaine on va se
permettent encore une autre paire
poursuivre pour les faits par qui oui
mais voilà le monde était le monde était
de fon montémont et et de fun vous vous
promène avec la brosse viens tu es les
amis vient les petits le plaisir d'être
en gagne bien tissé des liens vivre des
expériences avec du monde même assez
générales et contenant les noms mais
c'est quand même moi même le nombre
d'amitiés ou d'expérience de de sages de
lumen que j'ai créée cet été
en étant sa brosse sent particulièrement
au web sans savoir un été qui veut
non mais non mais c'est maintenant c'est
pas le mal était déjà fait
mais dans le fond j'ai jeté sur un
spectacle où cet avis qui le passé l'été
sur mamma mia la comédie musicale qui
ont certes est pas mal après les choses
ce répit mais là en même temps le monde
des mondes de m'habiller va quitter ce
pivot facettes mais le temps afin de
voir la dernière semaine de chaudes
j'étais comme fatigué mais j'en suis
capable
j'ai mieux même le faut que ça aura été
en même temps je te jure qu'il reste on
dirait une semaine de chaud je vais y
aller jusqu'au bout je te réponds bah
ouais on va sortir des trois derniers
soirs s'adresser je vais être bon je
vois que je suis reposé ben jaafar ramos
directeur dès que quelques jours off où
allez-vous toit par exemple c'est infini
comme un gros stress c'est comme tonton
repolie drastique examen non seulement
je crois que tu te reposes mais c'est
quand même plus d'alcool
non c'est cela que ces coupures juste
parce que rose cooper et où je pense je
pense à la bhl qui est tout le temps sur
la route ou qui l'accompagnent de plus
en plus souvent qu'on rentre à la maison
a le style on parler d'alcool qui comme
kid qui ne devrait pas être une excuse
pour ne pas être productif même salée la
tournée c'est la seule excuse je pense
quand tu te rendes tourner ces trois
jours où la bouffe sonata pas tu fais
rien des dettes je serai juste d'être
sétois après tout petit fils benoît
était notamment d'amener un mois sans
alcool je crois que ça quand ça fasse
bien mais tant pis puis tu vois je te
mal c'est moi j'ai comme une phobie de
développer des mauvais partout mathon
cefac les ça a été vraiment intense à
ambri d'alcool plus
dans les jours et à prester comme as tu
méritais l'état dans un contexte le goût
d'une bombe hier et aujourd'hui
plusieurs bonnes garanties
sauf que le boîtier moi j'ai jamais
allemande et il faut comme ça aussi pour
être le moins de monde mais c'est ça
mais tout les city comme il ya plusieurs
sphères de notre vie est nourrie en même
temps de trouver l'équilibré la demande
s'ils voient justement la sphère sociale
cet été même monde était légendaire
mepha social était comme siemens fallait
était nourri mandajors comme jamais
c'est un smartphone c'est tellement un
bon feeling c'était bien entouré d'avoir
des bons amis des livres aux
fondamentaux mais après ce métier
d'autres d'autres faire appel je l'avais
dit c'était notre première fois qu'on
s'est vus là c'était sabreuses mauvais
pour moi touchez pas de commentaires sur
les sites brushless un point ici de
jardin c'est le genre de moment parce
qu'ici comme qui est moi j'écoutais j'ai
cru que j'allais les mongueurs avant
d'aller à od quand je suis connaissait
par coeur le type le sort parce que j
accepte de sortir de montferrand je le
fais sans les cheveux des situations
sociales du genre tabarnak la wii qui
développe ce genre et ph g colleau koné
paniquée elle mais je me when non mais
oui à voter le ping pong club mon vieux
je suis à vous de voter pour adam hall
et les jets poche vote chaque semaine
celui-là
s'il réussit là je suis la manne c'est
intéressant au décès pas je trouve
qu'elle est ce qu est ce que tu
l'écoutés en version ce que tu l'écoutés
en version des connexions et mentale ou
quand même quand même nom mais je ne
sais pas comment j'ai l'impression qu'il
fut un temps où comme aimait audi
c'était comme honteux weight vous savez
de quoi aujourd'hui dans n'importe
quelle sphère gens c'est comme avant les
jeux c'est papy honnêtement pas du tout
je sais pas j'ai l'impression g j'ai des
amis genre universitaire gens qui capote
sur wii je dis je sais pas où un jeune
chirurgien soudards qui a pas de se
roder je sais pas n'importe qui 1.5
million de personnes que les quotas
chance voilà c'est même josé mais celle
ci si moi ce n'est pas un plaisir
coupable gens mais on observe des gens
dans la même tranche d'âge même qui qui
qui s'aiment qui s'engueulent quelque
chose est quelque chose d'essentiel âgés
que moi je regarde c'est comme une
expérience
c'est ça c'est ça que je voulais dire
c'est pas vraiment ou juste beau parce
qu'on le jet doit-on vraiment je me suis
sociologique la bac est qu un espèce d
excuse bien ce dos aux intellectuels
justement mano dimanche ben tu manges
dewey
monde crie à l'écran mais c'est le bon
bout
en fait il plus la psychologie moi
j'essaie de moi j'aime ce décoder les
gens que je rencontre je suis pas psy
pour 200 je connais vraiment pas su
montrer que tu as envie d'essayer des
ailes à tel trouble de personnalité ou
jean levi's et uni tel comportement a
progressé comme drôle de voir différence
de comportement des différentes
personnes qu qui se raconte entre les
gens qui le regardent ça étudié d'un
autre oeil pour être considérés comme
des discussions genre voire
anthropologique
je trouve que je souhaitais pas à lire
avec une espèce de détention un peu
genre pas tout à fait jeudi comme
seesmic pour quelques jeux allaient
avoir du fun d'aller à votre iphone puis
je pense que tout le monde mon année y
allez un petit peu deuxième niveau théo
avec ce qu'on connaissait daudet avant
que ça revienne je pense que tout le
monde y allait avec un petit peu
deuxième niveau de façon détachée en
pendant 10 ans on rigole on rigole du
concert exactions des siens on se prête
au jeu
sa chance c'est quoi le jeu mais
finalement je suis tout le temps pour
faire tourner mais c'est ça la fin mais
le jugement des gars tchouga metidji
dangereux trop le jeu aussi dans
l'hexagone
gris au niveau du mot qui avait pas dans
le terme et on le sait lui qui m'a fait
remarquer surprendre parce qu'on en
parle être des fois tu avais c'est quoi
ce qui s'appelle le guide animateur le
benoît sébastien sébastien benoit c'est
sébastien benoit à lui c'était comme ce
soir
occupation de ses côtés c'est ça son
animation l'armée pee wee aussi est un
peu un petit lancer quelques flèches peu
plus poney ou en gouaille quand il y
avait ces interviews on monde avec
quelqu'un il commande ils sont onze
questions si la personne avait fait des
bévues ou des noirs que peu croche ça se
ressentait le croire un léger juin jeu
juste le plus qui peut y aller demain
cgc unsa ce sous forme de blague la
menthe qui sont d'ailleurs souvent très
net sales allège un peu aussi bien le
espèce de droit sur place ou basque ou
en tant que spectateur on dit ok on
n'est pas que je la prenne au sérieux et
c'est en écoutant ce bien voulu prendre
tout son sérieux qui mais j'avais déjà
temps de sébastien benoit commenter
cette ses pizzas
je pense j'ai que toutes les autres
c'est la thématique c'est benoit je
n'aime pas sébastien benoit 061 anime ce
bip
je pense que c'est le cannabis
grand amateur mais je pense que le ton
est aussi donnée lui disaient qu'ils
n'avaient aucune marge de manoeuvre le
fallait qu'ils soient sérieux comme la
prod en ce temps là apparemment que
c'était parce qu'à ce moment c'est
encore y avait les mains là dedans mais
je ne peux pas dire est que ça va être
ça qui importe qui est adjacent à me
contrôler tous les niveaux de l'émission
n'ont pas le niveau mais si tu vois
cette année qui à calgary ce tapis rouge
puis dijon de l'énergie depuis gerald
les yeux je sais comment c'est drôle a
créé ces participants qui se présente
pays savent qu'ils peuvent être objet
d'un roulage est un éminent le fait que
ça laisse place à dumont ne peut plus
vrai je crois ou du moins leur côté un
peu plus vert - préparer plus sporadique
grand bleu ça donne ça donne la bonne
télé jour cette question l'a dit c'est
qui qui c'est qui qui est qui qui
l'épaule ouais mais pas à temps la
production mondiale julie un dictaphone
attend attendait la construction
[Rires]
qu'est ce que voulez vous la joseph c ur
de faire la part des choses en quelqu'un
qui qui a l'air d'un peu cabot tant aimé
quelqu'un qui fait exprès d'avoir leur
cabas twenty ouais mais ton quelqu'un
qui se présente ses comptes et adamo
mettons-la adamo 4 suis pas le seul
khatri par l'humanité richard park
medicom rigolo vieri qui est rigolo sûr
que sauf que maintenant quand tu regarde
comment étaient les thons sous taillé
rougeole et 17 mai langue salée à 100%
celtique
parce que c'est comme y est comme ça y
est comme ça c'est une extrapolation de
sa propre personne mais quand tu vas
être t ou en lan wan avec lui il va pas
avoir site des jardins groupe grotesque
naïveté lisicki qui montrait pendant
l'émission
[Musique]
je me souviens de son tapis rouge qui
t'arrive et puis je rappelle à d'amour
je suis stressé il était comme il jouait
un peu les nerveux il y avait travaillé
son texte si ce succès avec l arrivée
non mais je vais essayer comme ça pour
vrai à tisser son humour car après ça
c'est quoi le sait qu'ici où c'est assez
ou qui a commencé aux affinités
je préfère quelqu'un qui je préfère
quelqu'un espèce de textes répété oui ou
comment se mouiller fait exprès c'est
fake maladroit qu'un texte prochain
union jund que genre quelqu'un qui qui
qui arrive avec un espèce de quota
je sais pas qui le que mes grands
parents sont mariés depuis 50 ans ses
grands parents
mais cette année je trouvais qu'il y en
avait eu 12 défaites en coupe caf
cet exemple précisément surtout de ce
que tu recherches
[Rires]
séné j'avais je veux avoir d'alors les
belles valeurs pitt s'est amené à
manille dit qu'ils étaient les valeurs
familiales pic et recherche à grantham
haute et aop je peux plus je sais qu est
ce qu est ce qui serait comme procréer
acceptable cool comme quel genre de
discours moi je trouve qu'il serait
parfait ce genre de 12 comme nous ferait
pas comme tesco rappel historique items
les tapis rouges pour moi c'est cette
année je les patchs et qu'ils singent
les patchs et qui j'en ma blonde le
tchèque et puis genre comme sajoo et moi
j'écoute le quotidien mais le tapis
rouge et y meurent ils me demandent
beaucoup jean le tapis rouge - de décès
[Applaudissements]
monsieur octobre avec ma blonde je
l'écoutais pas ouais comme il ya
beaucoup de moments où est ce que
j'aurai juste fermé le laptop chaque
enfant non non non écouter mais j'ai
manqué parce que c'est quand même long
tapis rouge ce ne serait pas le plus
animé
mais will et moi je trouve d'anciens
combattants est-ce que tu prennes le
rester j'en remets ton je demanderai pas
l'alpha mais est-ce que tu t'en souviens
que je salue les faits datent elles
parce qu'elles go j'ai 26 ans je suis né
à chicoutimi
j'ai grandi à québec depuis tout petit
j'ai un imaginaire vraiment débordés
c'est vrai ça je me souviens j'aime ce
le plus possible à mener dans la vie de
tous les jours puis en insistant un peu
ce que je cherchais une expérience
qu'elle aime faire sortir du confort de
tous les jours pire trouver quelqu'un
qui avait qui peut-être jamais pouvoir
se gèlent pouvoir faire ce jusqu'à fin
août comme seul cadeau c'est une belle
tarte au sucre baltard c'est ok assez
parler de nous et pas assez parlé des
génériques est devant moi j'ai bien trop
de questions qui ont pas cet effort mais
bon je te revois ton show à l'impérial
de québec festival était le 3 1 c'était
avant que si on avant que j'allais eau
des puits
c'était la soirée mais tel que moi et
que j'étais venu en bas tu es après ça
je les monte à coursan après ton choix
toi qui est fait afin de tons chauds un
gros segment sur faute de système doit
être prête d'oublier
puis tandis qu'ils avaient beaucoup de
programmes beaucoup des femmes plus
âgées qui était à metallica il y avait
beaucoup de jeunes femmes dans sa vie
j'étais pas sûr que tout le monde avait
cette référence le de jean leloup que tu
ramènes dans ton derrière extrait qui
pensaient nous
je joue de la guitare pourquoi cette
chanson là avec une place aussi
importante d'un ton dans la main le
pourquoi précis je sais pas je trouve
juste que c'est extrêmement clair eu
cette phrase la meilleure chanson de
jean leloup et vous ça serait propre
possiblement a préféré aussi mais j'aime
beaucoup l'amour y sentent ici aussi
mais l'album complet mais à noël mais le
pour qu'on m'aime je sais pas s'il me
sens incroyablement bon même cette place
là
en fait il ya aussi que disons que je
vais écrire une espèce de je vais écrire
une espèce de couplets quitterait comme
quitterait rap très vantarde très bon
vous voyez où je m'en vais il va
toujours falloir que je le coupe avait
quelque chose d'un peu de sérieux puis
d'un petit peu morbide un petit peu dans
le genre on veut réfléchir quoique ce
soit mais je trouvais que le bridge
reprend ce après un après un espèce de
couplets qui traite de tout et de rien
genre sur juste moi qui ai fly je
trouvais que ça venait bien cassé puis
[Musique]
puis c'est après dans la chanson je dis
je vais juste parler de contraire
octobre c'est bien peu dire on frôle
amant mais nul c'est vivre tout ce qu'on
sait c'est qu'on sait tous on prend du
pont bleu des livres i go sodome sais je
fais l'éloge de la quel point on
utilisera mais à quel point elle est
imbécile en même temps je sais pas c'est
que j'avais un groupe
j'avais un gros couple est super menteur
puis après quand ça lui chante années
que genre est-ce que c'est réfléchi ou
comme c'est normalement comme pas
vraiment ce que je dis ce que je crois
ce que je fais je sais peut-être je
pense que ça venait juste bien détrôner
jean vie pour moi utiliser quelque chose
de de jean leloup surtout ses phrases de
c'est quelque chose que j'ai extrêmement
fiers de faire genre vraiment puis j'ai
vraiment c'est tout le jeu joue l'acteur
souvent souvent chantonnay part du monde
c'est le parti qui ont leurs frais en
tête mais qui écoute pas les couples
elles n'ont aucune idée de quoi ça parle
pis quand tu parlais tout à l'heure de
l'espèce de contradictions de de radical
chic non que toi tu portais à ta propre
personne puis le
espèce de la wii qui dès l'aube takes
over analystes l'espèce de larry kids on
veut intéresser par par les ormes et les
week ends en même temps l'esprit de
contradiction là-dedans pile le les
grands instants de lucidité qui ont rien
de lucide tu l'espèce d'idées de comme
j'ai une lucidité qui n'est pinel
l'épaule
je trouve que je trouve que c'est
vraiment un beau jeu de belles
dichotomie dans est aussi dans l'ordre
mais certainement sa folie sinistres
déclarés au fait que c'est comme si je
sens que j'ai réussi j'ai pas parce
qu'on est souvent la voir comme ça va
vraiment pas bien
c'est comme ça va vraiment pas je
grandin grandissant du site et qui est
comme blanc jean la musique c'est un qui
vient comme sauvée il ya plein de façons
d'être prêté ses piges puis j'aime bien
de prêter à toutes ces têtes après tests
sur l'homme et c'est intéressant de
parler de cette chanson qui est un peu
en dessous gn histoire je veux raconter
mon histoire d'or géant bleu fait une
tournée qui s'appelait le fantôme de
paradis cité après son son album à part
à dc os qui était tout seul et un énorme
crâne sur la scène qui avaient des
mappings de projection dessus sinon
c'est lui avec sa guitare d'exemple en
dons puis il commence à jouer cette
chanson le plus et c'est tout le monde
pas vraiment attention pis ce qui est
intéressant dans ce show là c'est qu'ils
y modifier les mélodies fait que ça
permettait de re découvrir les textes
vue puis il se met à jouer cette
chanson-là puis un gars complètement
arraché qui montre ce stage pendant le
refrain qu'il parlait ce bol qui fait à
quoi j'ai joué qui se met à crier plus
jean-louis fargette le regard des airs
est de jouer je viens chercher le gain
est assassin qui l'amène tout le monde
genre silence complet dans le grand
théâtre puis l'a fait parce que j'en
étais là dessus
moi qui complètement goff je viens une
perdre complètement l'espèce de
brindilles d'étincelles du moment que
tout le monde vivait ensemble d'écouter
cette musique là revisité intimiste le
vote lui et pull up et je pense même pas
que c est aux offres de la situation non
c'est parce qu'ils sont sont humiliés
des événements qui sont kiki qui relève
de quelque chose de plus que toi qui te
bri - je pense qui exactement
je pense que lui comme son l'espèce de
d'ouverture qui nous offrait la nature
fermer automatiquement puis le reste du
show ça a été comme barclays tf1 il
comme regarder ça cette laisse à ses
pieds et comme dit j'aimerais encore
prêt à faire pour vous mais j'ai plus
qu'à jouer
bonne soirée qui est parti non à partir
de ce moment le petit tout le monde
tripet jusqu'à 6,7 à peu près aux deux
tiers du show le tien c'est arrivé et
puis le dernier tiers du show il était
juste
puis le pont tout y passe quand j'ai
vraiment lutté jean leloup j'ai
l'impression qui est capable dans le
moment sans penser à qui le jeune chaux
tantôt c'est la soi disant qu'il
toujours lui il les choisit suspects -
justement pour qu'il soit 100 % - deux
fils et j'ai l'impression que les
s'offrait à comme le public qu'il
recevait pis puis la seule celle de jean
blaise senghor aucune sensibilité voire
une fragilité vraiment est à fleur de
peau le gars qui est monté sur le style
stange qui n'a aucune sensible médecine
intelligente jean leloup seuil et déjà
qu'il apprécie pour différentes raisons
les gens qui l'apprécient pour tritex
mais quand même fait des études et
spiritueux beaucoup tourner au but
d'apporter de même les tonneaux bébel
zahir et écoute pas les textes mais
quand on écoute les textes évoqués celui
ci me sens très pessimiste mais c'est
exact mais je crois que 997 en espèces
de bois guitare qui était chantonnay
comment mineurs des pics jim de serre
vite arriver you know what our moi je
crois je vais
la présente loi la majorité de ces taux
ne sais pas ce qu'il doit composer lui
extincteur non mais je dis rien il y en
a qui l'ont quand même un élan joyeuse
ouais mais je crois que je crois que
1990 n'était pas jean faisait ses adieux
de bran van ly a fait qu'un bureau en
valeur on voit là on voit la guette un
peu d'un site
je crois savoir super bien c'est jusqu'à
près ceci ma tante est fan de cette
énergie le toit
jean leloup en solo mettre au panier
dominé moi je voulais qu'on parle un peu
aussi des officiels je trouve ça
vraiment mais au delà au delà de l'objet
l'ange au delà du linge tipi de comment
je trouve que les jeunes trouvent soit
de dire à qui tu es confère le couac est
quand même j
quand même niche
quand même haute couture anguilles mais
accessible ton résolument haute couture
hcc je peux te la mets une grosse
guillemets mais quand tu décrire et
maintenant c'est pas tout ça mais leur
part les grands designers sais pas ce
qu'il faut c'est compliqué le japon met
à parler ça mais c'est de la couture
mettons maintenant avec la et dans des
matériaux simples ans seulement puis de
rendre ce c'est bon mais de rendre ce
mainstream le nom de personne que je
vois se promener ne serait ce qu'avec le
moral mais demi ou avec des barres mars
paraît super reggie que tu vois nulle
part je trouve ton tour de force faire
ce coup je crois que ça te plaise mais
je sais aussi que c'est quelque chose
sur lequel je ne contrôle vraiment oui
je sais
la mode la mode la mode
non mais je disais le linge ça fait
tellement des années que je dis je que
je suis ça que j'adore ce que je dessine
je loge
j'en ai fait moi j'ai vue d'acheter huit
avaient montré un sketch box il avait 20
ans affiche décidé de scinder robe avec
des effets fumay mais j'ai toujours
beaucoup de monde fonce metal sédiments
qui peuvent même temps rend plus à vrai
dire c'est un mois mais non la requête
s'improvise designers mais ouais je sais
pas si je suis à l'aise avec le fait de
0,2 en mai mais toujours est il que dans
les tests que oui je sais pas par choix
d'assumer maintenant officiel c'est des
dessins qui sont qui deviennent des
patrons qui deviennent des créations
c'est pas comme au début je sais faire
imprimer des lettres sur des jack doit
s'est fait de plus en plus les termes d
un ne s'applique mais
je sais pas mais je n'avais pas trop de
comment dire ça je vais pas dire que je
savais que ça allait marcher officiel
mais j'étais pont n'était pas je ne sais
pas comment dit on aime c'est c'est les
premières idées qu'on a eue avec
officielle du départ et qu'on l'avait
fait officiel c'était tout d'abord un
projet couture que tu t'es comme des
idées vraiment ambitieuse de couture de
travail et de retravailler des valises
en gros coton avec du patchwork est
toute petite quantité
ensuite de ce on a eu des opportunités
d'acheter des violences de sport des
années 90 qu'on a modifié
on a décidé de modifier puis à travers
le succès de ce qu'on a fait c'est qu'on
est revenue à la couture ce qu'on
voulait ultime en renfort depuis ses
débuts pour se prouver parce que
honnêtement une bonne idée graphique
pointé sur un tee shirt blanc ou sur
evre quoique si une star noire en soie
psy ops game en soit c'est se démarquer
dans le streetwear et je suis très
proprement dit je dois pas de la couture
le jeudi est comme faire apprendre des
choses sur un tee shirt du match mais
s'est quand même c'est simple à faire
mais si tu es bon dans des bombes dans
l'ain jean pigeon moi je moi je salue
toutes les marques genre un peu moche
qui sont comme que c'est ça faire un bon
ben raide avec ça puis qui m'est fait
que ça à la fin tu officiel ses revenus
à ce que ça voulait faire c'est la
couture c'est cela la couture sans
compromis entre un des gros matériaux
cheikh lô durable
si on peut des trucs recycler des truc
c'est de faire attention pas notre belle
planète nos t-shirts sont en coton
recyclé mais juste le texas préfet local
aussi de fin de match entre deux sens
c'est pour ça que ses charges s'il est
ce que c'est fait à montréal gaz je vous
dis là mais nous on a t on à un atelier
un petit atelier là c'est fait à
montréal tout est fait à montréal
gayssot comme dessus il ya du monde qui
se plaignent ben vous savez j'ai
l'impression que ça fait partie de moi
j'ai des amis pilotes chadal parce que
c'est des gros fans de toiles immenses
aux requins en être qui tripent sur la
la mode - puis me semble que j'avais
s'additionner avec eux me semble que ce
ça fait ça fait partie de l'expérience
en ont certainement j'ai l'impression de
ces six mois je vais me panier en
jaquette officielle
je veux que ce soit somme toute
exclusif un guillemets ça c'est sûr ça
va mais quelque chose que quelque chose
que je paye pour tout ce que ça
représente pour ses maisons ses rangs la
lune et les matériaux puis la production
ou est-ce que ça a été fait mais je paye
aussi pour ce que ça représente celle ci
met un très bonne attitude par rapport à
tes habitudes de consommation brute mais
je suis vraiment du fait d'une fille
d'une fille de 19 ans gens qui comme qui
vient de commencer une diversité puis à
temps partiel à la pharmacie où c'est
quand même plus cette offre pourrait le
lâcher en cours de 300 pièces
oui mais moi je dirais à cette règle ou
à n'importe quoi n'importe quel plus
jeune étudiant france d'officiels qu'ils
veulent c'est comme vaut mieux mettre
des sous de côté d'attentes s'acheter un
cote officielle puis de quand il porte
voix capoter va durer vraiment longtemps
volant nous nettoyage à sec y voir
sortir les matériaux va être tout mouthe
ep câble
nous avons fait débat me textile de
recouvrement chaise de 600 mhz d un
disque c'est fake c'est coc aux gens de
choisir en connaissance de cause courant
ses méfaits mais je peux dire de quoi
ces officiels ce qu'on livre aux gens
c'est s'il n'y a pas de compromis disant
ça je peux le sont peu le promets de
l'apport de dalein et moi qui venons la
marque le jardin de shit pisser à petite
échelle puis c'est beaucoup d'amour
c'est une petite équipe encore je sais
pas je sais pas personne si pour pousser
la mode on parle de baisser les prix oui
je tâche quand je comprends aisément que
ce 10ème et du moment que tu ressens
qu'est-ce que tu payes commencé pour le
fait que ça soit fait à moréac les
matériaux sont en tête c'est parce
qu'ils y aussi des brent des grosses
graines ou qui comme du prestige associé
à ce que tu le sais que large de leurs
côtes
c'est une pièce pi tallevende 50
piastres
mais je trouve qu est-ce que vous avez
russe a créé en fait quelle place dès le
tour de force qui réussit à avoir été
fait piquer le plus important c'est de
tirer un sentiment d'appartenance avec
cette marque les objets tout à fait que
la marque s'inscrit dans une sous
culture je peux je pourrais dire jusqu'à
contre-culture métier le fait qu'il y
ait vraiment du monde qui s'identifient
à cette marque îlots de manière si comme
moi qu'acheter qui est des cibles que
j'étais un petit pont qui puisse porter
les veines depuis j'avais déjà les vols
comme ces temps difficiles il ya deux
personnes mais oui un sentiment
d'appartenance
ce capitaine marc ce que le plus de
valeur je pense à non mais certainement
puis on est
je pense qu'on est un peu conscience
pions on est extrêmement reconnaissante
si c'est vous le recommander le service
à la clientèle je suis officiel c'est
les clients sont son facebook
à 3h30 du matin ça ne soit pas de
réponse évidente
évidemment comme avant gbagbo les
employés de dom non mais on a un contact
avec les clients qui est vraiment
personnalisé dans la mesure où où on
souhaite souhaite que les gens se
sentent comme je suis vraiment aussi
kung fu d'acheter chez nous puis d'être
les privilégier sa pensée à paris on y
voit là est ce que j'imagine qu'ils
aiment
lahoud avec le succès qui a eu depuis le
fait qu'il y ait plein le brent ça l'a
aidé énormément je prends pas meilleur
ambassadeur que lui vraiment mais josé
moi j'ai chaque fois que j'ai dû
je veux qu'on ait de nouveaux trucs
officiel moi j'en donne à la ddt par
amitié oui mais oui et viendra stripped
amitié évidemment puisque modularité moi
jamais dit jean et aux baux pour le club
sur 2 juin mais le trou possible
d'arriver au club soda pendant sa
chanson - hypothèse officielle y arriver
on va boire un verre de bon vin avec
simon pis jorion officielle sous lui
passe à 80 le tout à fait mais c'est
fake c'est encore plus cool de savoir
que ça ça relève même pas de jeter mon
bol gens c'est comme juste je le cite
barrès et flight c'était vraiment pitié
cessez ça participe à ce que tu dis est
entre autres du sentiment d'appartenance
parce que la raison pour laquelle je le
jugerai contre culture quand tu parais
tantôt c'est que c'est vraiment
il ya vraiment poussé ont dirait que le
brent officielle est lié à un espèce de
espèce de lever des jeunes qui s'assume
plus dans dans la lampe dans la place du
québec lors qu'ils aiment consommer
prend sa place t on dirait que
compterait que dans le même temps porter
leurs actions officielles et afficher
directement lié directement au fait qu
il ya un rapport de rapture qui fait le
centre ville
maintenant on dirait que c'est dans la
même vague à mon avis une espèce de
rébellion contre les choses qui était
déjà établie session un peu plus lourde
archaïque
voilà on dirait qu'il sort avec avec le
brent qui on sait que les deux mois vont
vraiment ensemble de départ je sais pas
qu'est ce que c'est l'ensemble des deux
qui crée sa gelée presley ben écoute une
analyse que j'ai comment dire que
j'aurais pas pu avoir la prétention de
dénoter ça comme ça mais c'est sûr ça
fait extrêmement plaisir ce que tu
disais puis je dirais ben oui même puis
au centre bell datant dé tout dsk
maintenant qu est ce qui prend plus de
place l'a rappelé à la marque les deux
égards même si c'est quelque chose qui
vous fort que cheikh
parce que
parce que les deux les deux ça dépend
c'est très rarement les 2 en même temps
quand je compte sur la musique j'y suis
à fond plat comme là c'est la musique me
donne une espèce de trois semaines of
legends backs officiel jean marc four
officiel les ateliers n'arrête pas de
travailler il faut faut s'occuper des
clients du tout mais il faut juste faire
deux collections par année des idées de
genté avec dana faut avoir des idées de
jacques saint comme 40 morceaux par
année aux nouveaux puits allez allez
magasiner les matériaux du tout celui ci
de là john à la jam en crise c'est
tellement fun c'est tellement le fun
pour devrait aller aller voir un niveau
légal atelier puis travailler avec lui
et qu'il fallait s'impose avec un dd
s'impose à la maison puis débattre avec
jean ma blonde de ce que vous allez vous
c'est quoi le prochain truc c'est
beaucoup d'heures c'est très demandant
mais c'est que c'est très long pour moi
mais je
à moyen terme je sais pas qu'est ce qui
va se passer avec mon temps je sais pas
comment ma personne une extension de moi
même
[Musique]
mais quand j'étais le feeling doit être
sensiblement similaire le feeling de la
création dans le fond montée d'arrivée
cannes album d' avec une nouvelle
collection
non c'est partie de toi la base puis il
ya un produit qui existe c'est quelque
chose qui est qui qui est milliardaire
c'est pour les genres à savoir mais tout
ce que le feeling et les semblables ou
totalement oui c'est peut-être le
processus qui est différent je dois le
la musique c'est pour comment dire la
ville et pour moi c'est difficile mais
c'est difficile pour moi genre comme ce
fait comme 16 ans je rappe comme
convaincu de mes moyens droit comme donc
dans le tournoi g de baies starter 2010
mais sauve que parce que c'est
excessivement demandant pour moi parce
que c'est parce que c'est comme ça comme
écrire un créer un gros buzz sera pour
moi c'est vraiment demandant c'est comme
quand j arrive par exemple si je vois la
table c'est vraiment satisfaisant mais
cette offre a set of moi même ma
compétition mais modèle c'est comme si
des gars comme la compare au québec la
fecq
j'entendais tu peux passer loeb quelque
chose comme il faut tu t'en vas freight
en afrique correct enverront leurs
écrits le nombril en six mètres
jusque là mods ex un peu plus par gagner
mais je veux dire on est ce que c'est
arrivé plus par hasard ou est ce que
c'est que ce sourire dans ta vie ordre
est passé à wake qui tu savais déjà
j'ai rencontré de la main puis on
ma blonde t on comme elle aussi était
maman est allée elle était semée creux
aussi dans des bas mais elle a fait
beaucoup de si les soirs et galeristes
les dons et jusqu'en serbie est fautif
je parte a marqué quand je vais être là
comment on fait le marque de linge comme
si c'est parce qu'à mon sens que tu
l'aies pas fait avancer
on sait je suis né là j'espère
maintenant maintenant c'est ci dessus
les langues jeu c'est l'europe qui paye
le loyer c'est les deux à égal dans les
dernières années c'est le seo la main
quand même le linge quand même et ça a
changé
ouais je pense que tu veux toi je sais
ça va pas changer je pense que les deux
vont chose que de nos maîtres que le
linge ont eu de la chance de la chance
de bien travailler que la neige puis que
ça marche bien je dis juste que faut
aussi prendre en ligne de compte que moi
mes années de mes dernières années de
musique était pas super active non plus
si j'écrivais tout j'aime beaucoup ce
sport j'ai quand même des redevances ici
et là qui sont intéressantes tapadas
stressé premier sas et c'est un autre
point g men j'avais une liste et y mon
gars je les dis beaucoup méchant fans
qui j'avais une liste d'affaires que je
voulais te parler je suis ça c'en est
une que je m'en voudrais de pas de
parler dernièrement les enfants un long
détour pour poser ma question
j'ai comme pas dernièrement même j'ai
commencé à perdre mes cheveux
et puis liées au stress j'ai des trous
et dans barbe notamment chez souvent
puis tout est allé voir un médecin de
mètres séparent liées au stress et à la
moncelle qui tout le temps dans mes
poches tient la vie qu'on quand même
avec ont choisi de mener mois puis ça
fait une couple de fois que je t'écris
pour le podcast
je suis au chalet ouais puis premier
buzz que tu fais dans off the grid un
dollar
c'est dire mais pour me voir c'est quoi
la ligne exact promouvoir la vie rapide
c'est aussi de passer ce genre de rester
inactif way juste au jeu c'est prévu des
paysagistes exactement ce c'est quelque
chose que consciemment tu fais juste
dire tu sais quoi mène la chérie mais
sont intéressantes mais je ne sais pas
vraiment où j'allais je l'admets c'est
bizarre je me demande si mon vieux
maître parce qu'on était au chalet si
j'étais au chalet au lac brome et
chalets non pour la gombe c'est dans les
laurentides mais j'étais au chalet puis
comme honnêtement mais non ne pas
arrêter comme jamais travaillé au top
comme ashley honnêtement qu'est ce qu'on
fait mais ce n'est pas les vacances mais
des fois non mais si cet outil pour
répondre à ta question là cette espèce
d'image la justice était c'est
souhaitable ancrer ces jeux c'est déjà
arrivé dans ma vie si je termine
évidemment mais dernièrement je vais pas
dire que oui j'en espèce de
vraiment un sentiment de décrochage peut
vraiment le dis à moi mais mémène
tchèque ce qu'on veut mais moi c'est
parce que je me dis moi je sais pas
qu'est ce coeur mais dont je sais pas
qu'est-ce que je serai prêt à sacrifier
en termes d'aboutissement de vie pour
pour me permettre ce cm et en admettant
qu' on se projette dans le futur qu'on
imagine un monde où est ce que mes
affaires fonctionnent bien puis je sais
pas qu'est ce que je sais pas quel est
ton
c'est la différence entre faire je veux
dire des chiffres de même l'europe ce
que je ferais jamais ça de ma vie mais
la défense en faire 500 milles puis un
million donc je sais pas si je serai
prêt à sacrifier
je sais pas où est ce que je serais prêt
à arrêter à 10 ans qui mène le tas si
grande île de man va-t-on schalit je
rachèterai chalets décorés que je
pourrais rester à 500 mille tonnes
déchets vraiment c'est surtout en
faisant ce qui est loin de métis parce
que j'ai l'impression que j'ai
l'impression que peut-être la société ou
juste mon désir de toujours être
meilleur
moi jamais me permettre de faire mais tu
le fais tu pour les sources pour ses
plans mais c'est ça qu'est ce exactement
ciom émettant mettons que le jeune
500000 prime un million parce que c'est
les choses qui se calcule même temps
mais tant que tu fais l'équivalent en
termes de gratification personnelle tu
es donc tout pour pitch tu fais un
salaire qui permet de vivre ta vivement
et sans vraiment posé de questions ou
est-ce que j'arrête la gratification
personnelle pour juste d'irak et manlleu
faut que j'aille rien qu'en lycées
pendant deux pendant un mois donc ouais
ben c'est 27 sept j'ose croire que du
monde peut-être que nous c'est qui s'est
si souvent d'autres personnes qui
viennent nous taper sur les
portefeuilles au slow dance
ouais c'est moi je le dis souvent je
travaille énormément
mais ouais mais je sais pas moi même je
sais pas te donner des objectifs
c'est pas parce que si c'est monétaire
ça peut te ça peut ça pique ça peut te
ronge et jusqu'à ce que tu attends ce
que tu veux mais je trouve pas que je
trouve que ce que j'allais dire c'est
pas juste à propos de l'argent mais je
crois que c'est se mentir que de dire
que c'est vraiment surtout dans l'art
dans le linge en un musée coup dans ce
domaine même dans les mêmes les peintres
ou même les artistes conception l'argent
reste un l'argent restant c'est une
façon qu'elle est pas là sans calculer
une façon de calculer succès et beaucoup
d'autres façons de calculer la musique
au québec mais la reconnaissance se
traduit souvent par non non ça dépend
comment la musique au québec je suppute
fera connaître aux en train de fatah
comme tu peux te faire reconnaître en
train de faire ton talent et si volant
du match avec elle et comme des blocs
louis 18 mois puis joe dante est boucle
nous avons choisi reconnaît on me
l'avait lasa marché sur le plateau joly
s'est présentée à rocles mon et évoque
l'inconnue qui avaient péri après le
monde de la mode qui di cambio lors si
nécessaire de signer des autographes et
été quand tes habits tout en vieux
jogging c'est à pas de jets cherche des
scènes pour les mettre dans ces choses
surtout ce fait des métiers justement
c'est pas le top
pas être reconnu non habitée et vice
versa battant quelqu'un je sais pas le
top bakir wall street qui a une vie
misérable et qui fait à part jean
toujours avec l'autre mais je voulais tu
es ce que tu dis tantôt tipi je le jure
ya l'histoire personnelle de personnel
ou si c'était à trois entre migros j'ai
commencé que consulter un psy lui même
s'était pourtant fait d'autres raisons
mais en jasant avec en main un thème
récurrent qui revenait puis elle a le
flag et ce dahmani s'assainit est un peu
plus à proposer mais les sentiments de
vouloir toujours plus et puis mettre une
pression sur soi même de faire plus être
meilleur dans toutes les soirées déjà
vouloir être meilleur dans les podcasts
vouloir elle même et la guitariste
vouloir plus m'entraîner plus fort et
plus ça c'est vouloir tout faire mais
plus tout le temps mais un point où
est-ce que ça mené angoissant amener
l'eau puis en même temps c'est que cette
personne le quai que je rêve depuis que
je suis tout ce qu'ils étaient j'aime
comment tu cette personne le qui fait
toutes ces affaires lui affrontera pied
celle qui est qui et qui joue avec sa
femme qui essaie de tout faire à fond
sarlat d'être capable de te poser tes
propres limites je sais ce qu'il
faudrait faire pour que je fasse médecin
même dans ma recherche de l'équilibré
chez déséquilibre est convaincu si je me
dis qu'il faut que je tienne l'equilibre
donc faut que j'aille me social se met
tout ceci comme des trucs que je me pose
tout juste vivre comment ceci dit je
réfléchis trop
le site ces taxis je voulais dire tais
toi tu es la meilleure conseil mais mais
oui c'est ce terme en il faut savoir
arrêter mais c'est dur quand ce que tu
fais est bon tic ans ça se traduit un
succès professionnel en genre beat
je donnerai en vouloir à vouloir être
meilleure personne et il valorise
beaucoup le travail aussi et on valorise
beaucoup de travail mauvaise affaire
moi je juge pas personnes qui i was est
favorisée mais non plus l'été je l'étais
vent longtemps genre je l'étais pas
longtemps le sujet quand en fait c'est
ma vie c'est comme si moi travaillons
beaucoup et puis comme si moi de rien
faire c'est un fake
ça dépend juste jusqu'à quel point tu es
à l'aise avec le fait de tes de france
et parle comme 3000 par annick d'être
bien tranquille faty sites comme tu veux
comme ça dépend il faut juste que tu te
sens ultime en comprenne ce que toi tu
veux puis après ceux qui comme moi même
en jeu qu'en ces temps ci on est on est
sur le qui vive dans un mois pour plein
d'eau aussi parce que ça me plaît ouais
ça me plaît si tu suscites et halte à
vis à bosser sur pleins d'eau si
différent mais c'est wade reconnaît très
rapidement les trucs qui sont wac pour
les éliminer ceux qui se demandent
choses comme les chances en même temps
de faire ce que tu veux vraiment vrai
aussi même changer la difficulté
la difficulté c'est quand tu veux trop
où tu veux beaucoup d'enfants c'est mon
problème c'est comme qui est ce que ça
sera la retraite je fasse ce jeu face à
face
enfin les choix ce que tu disais tantôt
c'est avec le dans un futur rapproché
qu'est ce qu'est ce qui se passe c'est
quoi qui va souffrir c'est qu'elle se
fasse tu vas souffrir de l'autre ou à
mes yeux rien qui va souffrir il ya un
qui va se ferait pas ce qu'on voit je
dirai ce que j'ai le goût de répondre
que dans neuf dans à peu prendre le
flambeau d'officiel mais donnaient tous
occupés c'est là bas et peut pas
rattraper sans bouffée de ses hôtes et
apter mais il faut que j'apprenne à
déléguer déjà certainement pas le
créatif ouest et les grands magasins ont
été tous les deux au début presque
nicole venu d'un coup de main tendue de
réseaux sociaux pleindoux de mélo nicole
plus plus sérieusement ce nom mais au
début nicole de panne est rentable et
nicolas puis dodo plus petits puis après
c'est après cette grande fête consacrée
à cette fin la dole à la poutine métier
que je dire les trucs mais je pense que
c'est l'aspect créatif kiki et qui
demande en soit ce qu'on a devant nous
de notre monde
[Musique]
mais honnêtement à y penser comme
puisque la musique c'est cyclique je
faisais moi j'ai besoin d'eux j'ai
besoin comme six mois un an pour écrire
un album où après l'achat des choses
entre les choses quand les choses ont
fait chaud je peux je peux me donner à
fond ciel sans problème
je me mets bon reste à voir si je vais
claque le ballon d'eau chaude faites au
lancement le 15 nov
nous avons une foufoune électrique y est
tout à fait un québec où soyez là les
gens qui 1er novembre non mais le paquet
d'avants juste un peu avant
ouais c'est bon ouais c'est clair on
invite les gens peuvent s'assortir s'il
ya encore des billets pour les fosses à
lisier maintenant il faut savoir un
touriste est prévu ce bouquet ou pas
encore tout va être annoncé en temps
voulu 1 est ce que c'est une façon de
dire que y'a rien confirmer vos autres
de votre beau jour un peu à droite b you
il en fait beaucoup de trucs sur
lesquels on travaille mais ça serait ça
serait juste maladroit de quoi que ce
soit mais il ya certainement une tournée
qui se trament puis on se concentre sur
les lancements par an les repousser à
partir de là avec trois à damir sur
carlo sur la vocation n'est pas de gaz
qui lui faisait une tournée comme
tournée avec ce mot c'est cool et du
maine tournée avec la wii c'est un
incident mode floch
qu'est ce que les examens
nos studios la mélasse qui non mais
parce que c'est quand même c'est comme
un double trouble moi pis carlos mais
avec crème je suis plein air mais il
faut pas se leurrer non plus de gens
n'entrevoient cette tour les landes le
râble comme beaucoup de fans mais c'est
beaucoup de boulot c'est beaucoup de
boulot beaucoup coûté exactement si on
n'est pas dupe ce qu'il faut j'ai une
belle opportunité de montrer aux jambes
a fait campagne à la fois que la part de
tangent scheer et j'ai très hâte mais je
sais à quoi m'attendre en attente de
boulot là dessus mais oui on va déraper
sur la saison sur 60 ans vieux bruay
c'est le fun carreman qui me continue
quand même de vous et d'avoir bâclé
après après tout un chacun de voter vos
carrières respectives traire hyman ce
fut un énorme plaisir
yeah yeah yeahs merci beaucoup même
verse merci à toi ex beaucoup soyez
sages soyez sages seulement vous même
à bientôt